[Music]
in trust no one news no I don't trust
nobody essay submitted by Fay loves JK
oh thanks fan - a former yahoo engineer
pled guilty to hacking thousands of
accounts these don't even shock us
anymore but before we get into that make
sure not to miss it on any videos make
sure to subscribe that's right
subscribe to Tiger belly no a lot
tighter we'll try to get to two minute
subscribers please I just have a tough
finish can you subscribe and unsubscribe
and then subscribe again and then tell
your friend to do the same algorithms oh
yeah
we're hacking YouTube this is some of
the content that you get here if you
like this kind of comedy get ready we're
all over it well Gilbert won't be in the
other one so just ignore this one yeah
but just subscribe they're all in order
alright so this story here a former
Yahoo employee pleaded guilty in a
federal courts to hacking about 3,000
oh no sorry 6,000 yahoo accounts
targeting younger women including his
personal friends and work colleagues in
order to look for news so horny 6,000
6,000 and his own personal friends and
family joke's on you nobody uses Yahoo
anymore what is a family but I use a
fantasy football but I post all my news
there are two suns
that's scary I wonder if he's sorting
through these 6000 and sometimes he'll
get a dick and he's like oh [ __ ] he's
like [ __ ] it one of those nights he's
like hey I'm working with well flesh is
flesh [ __ ] so he would say so not
only would he do that but he would
compromise the iCloud Facebook Gmail
Dropbox Oh other online accounts of
yahoo users while he was searching for
more private images this is what happens
when horny people get ahold of power
exactly because then he would once you
found intimate videos and photos he
would save them and he had them in his
home to jack off to yeah he stored them
in a small view the hype man for this
guy you know I'm just like why would
people send nudes over email or not just
that but like Dropbox iCloud they have
the right to do it Joe I'm
I don't know Dropbox maybe the files too
big maybe it's one professional do it
the email you can have like a little
footer but there's a two gigabyte max
you know so if you're doing a whole
jackoff video what's the other one we
transfer you to transfer my air bridge
Thanks but they expire the link expires
after a week or something yeah you guys
know you're smart man this is a
sponsored what's happening I don't know
but a full-on like masturbation
performance that's a long one I don't
know if it needs to be what is average
masturbate you know what performance
time you made a video of you Matsui if
you know like like if you're dating cuz
this is all ladies right and then it's
like if you're getting nudes and if
you're getting performances like well
damn man like if you're doing 4k high
quality that might be like a 30 gig 5k
do you should anything maybe just your
jerk-off session baby Joe's the guy who
posted jerk a 28-minute jerk-off video
of him and he checks it every day but
there's no views on it
and he said is this is this the same
mentality so if this guy wants to jack
off to his friends is it like the same
mentality where people they go they
can't wait for a celeb to leak a sex
tape yes or delete there they're like
there lets you their iCloud stuff oh I
can't get wait til this actress or
whatever or actor leaks dis like a
jackoff it's like when I was in seventh
grade and there was like a [ __ ] hot
teacher and you just wanted to see
you're naked so bad like it's that kind
of [ __ ] this is the present day like I'm
a hide in the closet and Jack off while
I watch somebody change that's what I
was gonna say I think it's more like the
warrior ism here where it's like you're
not meant to see this it's like I want
to see it much that was meant for her
boyfriend that's like I saw it that's
like those where people are renting
their babies and there's cameras and
Manship guys [ __ ] free ball walking
into that stuff yeah that's nasty who's
been a bunch of kisser
well like people jack off and the Airbnb
cameras catch them you know the Airbnb
camera is there to watch you change and
I supposed to be there and [ __ ] or
whatever yeah they're not supposed to do
it and I got like turns damn on huh yeah
but that don't worry your [ __ ] that
would have been funny though that
would've been fun I know if like
someone's just beating off and in the
muscle woman
the cameras like oh that's not what I
signed up for that's Joey there baby
yeah and he's like I got someone to
watch my jerk-off video yeah that's why
I never closed my blinds when I change
because I'm always like feel sorry for
your eyes yeah I don't even care if
people look at me we know you change
here I know we see you all the time but
then she always wants to close the
blinds when we're walking around naked
yeah cuz I'm not gonna give this [ __ ]
away for free I am Laura has a different
strategy okay he's trying to go viral
first and then start charging Jill is
already starting to charge that's why
your fan base is gonna stay small we're
bar you've got to go really big real
quick go big quick and then do a paywall
yep really smart yes they just two
different philosophies here yeah I like
the slow and steady growth yeah premium
content but like very small fanbase
which one wins I don't know I don't know
either
dude I always said if there was a family
vlog channel or like like that big
family go to a couple vlog Channel and
then they're like hey if you go here and
pay you can watch this [ __ ] that would
do crazy well we have that you have a
wife man make it happen
doesn't that girl the Trish matías or
some [ __ ] do that just paid us I don't
think she thought was just Payton Trisha
Paytas is one of the greatest trolls on
the internet in my opinion really she's
uh she's kind of big she's blonde yeah
but she's a youtuber and uh yeah I think
she does like nudes are porn or we did a
jakey news on her like years ago where
she was asking of dogs have Souls
there's like that dream she's done
several troll oh she does odd maybe she
doesn't make it mcbomb control yeah yeah
she also did like a I love Mitt Romney
video during the 2012 election she's a
good troll man and she doesn't like nude
she does naked MOOC bogs in like I don't
know if she does full-on porn or
whatever but I think she does full-on
for yeah you could like subscribe I was
like damn that's crazy why is that crazy
well I didn't know a youtuber would do
that [ __ ] this guy right we're gonna
take it down
take a [ __ ] hold Joubert yourself man
I don't know how youtuber would do both
yeah cuz most youtubers aren't that edgy
no matter how edgy they try to work the
show they're not that edgy [ __ ] are you
guys like the most edgy youtubers I'm
with you on that edgy no I'll slap
homeless who's edgy huh whose edge like
my Tali that guy he's edgiest you got an
edge you crazy but he's also kind of
like edge crazed cringe a little bit
mm-my too thirsty he's edgy just running
on a soccer field naked I feel like
people were doing that in the Roman time
well he was [ __ ] like gladiators
Caesar my dick yeah bid on my damn
there's a difference between shock edgy
which we are not
I think shocking edgy but we are
opinionated edgy so we'll say a lot of
[ __ ] that go against the grain sometimes
we're all so edgy lords as well I feel
like I'm pretty soft I just think the
world is pretty is even softer yeah I
don't feel like I am I like that world
view like I don't feel like I'm like
Marilyn Manson or like I don't know I
don't try to suck my own dick or
anything like that but it's like the
world I've liked the world those prints
then he tries to suck his own dick I
think you won't try to suck your own
dick if you could yeah you have you
tried for the same pleasure
don't get it wrong yeah I do it I'm
tired of this I'm tired of the stigma I
suck my own dick and I'm proud of it
well you're probably the only one that
could reach your own dick anyway Iago
employee serve so he was charged with
one count of computer intrusion and one
count of interception of a wired
communication but under the guilty plea
agreements [ __ ] he just has to come out
it's just to the computer intrusion
charge so he's currently released on a
$200,000 bond that's a expensive porn
account right there that's how much he
had to pay for all that jakhary and so
much work to - like hacking
look through and that's a lot what if
he's really smart on hacking so easy
looks got some more spank bank so he
could face five years in prison for a
computer intrusion charge and a fine of
$250,000 plus restitution I wonder if
he's already been through a porn binge
and then after a while he got
desensitized and he's like I need to be
more familiar yeah yeah hey there's some
hot ants out there
where are you I just had personal
friends I'm hoping it wasn't family you
ever thought it I got a many hot ants
yeah supid on my wedding oh they all
Nikki side are yourself Nikki said oh my
auntie is hot as [ __ ] shoutout
hey Artie I can't say on TV that you're
just saying auntie auntie I don't know
that though so I just call her Auntie I
took that I love that I'd be at B but
now you know that you know now that I
know that I'm gonna I'm gonna go even
hover on a blanket that's his auntie I
never had I never went
I never had the desire to jack off to my
friends so I would like to understand
what that's like
you never had a really good buddy that
you wanted to jerk off know what Steve
there was okay
so dude was like I had that one girl
across the street moment were like we
were friends and she was a tomboy and
[ __ ] and then she blossomed into a very
beautiful girl and it was one time like
we're playing and she was no we're like
the same age fool so it's not petal if
you're the sheep blossom into a
butterfly
I was like yum yum yo she was like a
great under me but anyways so like of
course when you're kids or I like you
know you don't got the horny juices for
each other and then like so we were
playing and then she was on the [ __ ]
it was a hot-ass day she had a [ __ ]
bikini top on and I was like [ __ ] and
then I had to run like back home to jack
off real quick and bust my nut and then
go back out and hang out with her again
[Music]
that's quick I know did you go back home
and close your eyes or keep it movin and
RDG or did you cuz almost I got horny
cuz she was wearing like daisy dukes in
the [ __ ] bikini top and we used to
like just [ __ ] spray each other with
hoses and all that [ __ ] right how old
are you it's a music video looks great
or something like are with each other
what the hell no like but in like I
don't know but we were I never saw her
that way like I like since like third or
fourth grade or whatever right so we've
been like friends and in junior high
coming around that [ __ ] goes down I'm
starting to [ __ ] jack off already
so that [ __ ] was like holy [ __ ] I
couldn't stop looking at her and [ __ ]
and then I was like that was the first
experience of like my friend turning
into someone that like turned me on but
I wouldn't even know what to do with
their like if we were I follows alone oh
hell yeah it's weird cuz now it's like
it's like it's weird cuz like so I'm
like y'all get a lot of like [ __ ]
dick pics and guys like wanting you guys
right but for me it's the same way like
the way I look at my mom like once you
pass the threshold of like available
content like available person or
whatever I'm just like there's no way
that you're in the sexual realm anymore
it's weird I don't know but we
understand I don't know how like I don't
know I don't know if we get it effect
your story yeah we relate so she was the
first girl that cross the - ladies felt
that first thing only yeah that's why I
wanted to clarify because he only said
first so like and yeah dude they're
outside [ __ ] and she's putting her
tits on the glass in Washington I think
that's a lot of people across the
threshold they started doing that kind
of stuff yeah exactly
that's breaking down barriers
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]